how is it that you prevent yourself from
getting into existential crises when it
seems at least to me from the outside
that you study similar not theories per
se but the free energy principle is
about existence and is about self-hood
so is your model so strong carl is your
model already so strong that you can
entertain these without worry that
you'll break yours or without that being
a potential possibility or is it because
you purposefully analyze it
dispassionately analytically
intellectually so that you're not
identifying with what you're writing
down on a piece of paper how is it that
you prevent yourself or is it
constitutional like by predilection by
personality you're not neurotic you're
not as neurotic as i am um
i think there's there's probably truth
to all that and um
and by being neurotic um you know that's
an entirely [ __ ] your neurosis are
absolutely essential to get through life
um you know i have a particular set of
neuroscience
um which you know i treasure and try to
try
yes um
but i think you're also right that um
some people might call this mentalizing
i think what you were doing is that you
were
in a
raw enthusiastic and creative way we're
just exploring different hypotheses
about the way that you yourself should
it exist um um relates to um you know
the rest of your
mind and and the outside world
but for you we got conflated with um
emotional states like anxiety
and
your self-worth and those evaluative uh
states of being um
so if you want to in your words be more
dispassionate about this kind of mental
exploration on the inside then you have
to um you you you have to train yourself
not to conflate the two
one way of doing that is to be cut to
mentalize
so mentalizing is usually taken as a way
of if you like
disentangling what we what we would
normally quite functionally put together
certain states of being um of a sort of
um intellectual sort or a indeed a
physical sort uh or just a contextual
sort usually come along with some
emotional valence effective um
aspect simply because that's the way the
world is so if you'll say
very late at night
um you're normally going to feel
fatigued it's like you know slightly
less robust you know in in a way
physically now it doesn't have to be
like that but that's the way that
normally the world works and that's the
way that you've learned to model
yourself
and
if you train to be a professional say
like an airline pilot trying to land a
plane at night or like a psychiatrist
who has to deal with these um has to see
people going through
um these um
emotional or valence or effective um
episodes whether it's uh sort of um
effective in the sense of uh you know
mania or depression or whether it's um
know the the the you know the
co-morbidity associated with psychotic
states uh say schizoaffective
schizophrenia uh sorry because effective
disorders um what's that
it's a mixture of um
abnormal mood um with having
psychosis of the kindness associated
with schizophrenia um so it's having an
emotional aspect to say delusions and
hallucinations for example oh i thought
that those those don't go hand in hand
so some people have delusions but
they're okay with it
yes yes
some people have hallucinations and and
would not uh would not even seek medical
help or their family and friends would
not not seek
help
so there are people out there i guess my
point
you know um here is that you can
mentalize it and build professional
defenses against the emotional aspects
and i think that's what i've done so i
think about these things as a doctor or
a mathematician not as a person